this report from our moscow
correspondent diana magnay contains some
flash photography
this was an astonishing act of courage
five seconds on state tv that millions
will have watched don't believe the
propaganda
a relatively small fine but there may be
more to come
[Music]
we asked the man often called russia's
chief propagandist the head of media
empire russia sivonia what he thought of
it
is
ukraine is more united than it has ever
been and there are people in their
basements with the bombs falling on them
calling their parents in russia and
their parents don't believe them because
it's not shown on state tv
what do you make of that
absolutely
two other russian state tv journalists
announced their resignations today one
of them a long time presenter who'd left
the country a few days ago and the other
a foreign correspondent who was already
based in europe because if you oppose
what russia is doing it is safer to be
outside the country than in
protesting inside russia tends not to
end up well
this woman is holding up a sign which
literally says just two words
enough to see her taken in
and then this woman too who was
explaining how she opposed the protests
15 000 people detained since putin moved
into ukraine
in such circumstances like we have
nowadays
it's really difficult to
be
completely free and do whatever you want
unfortunately i think we need peace
of course it's my own position
that is a position shared across the
world just not perhaps by the one man
who could make it happen
donna magna sky news moscow